our national collapse continues as more
statues come tumbling down it's very
difficult to keep track of all the
statues that have come down
you remember initially it was just
Confederate monuments then it was robert
e lee who's got kind of a more special
place then very quickly it was Thomas
Jefferson George Washington Christopher
Columbus well we've got even more
statues coming down over the weekend a
quick rundown first ulysses s grant this
one maybe you were not expecting a
ulysses s grant is of course the union
general who freed all of the slaves so
you'd think that in the name of black
lives matter probably wouldn't make
sense to tear down his statue but that's
exactly what they did in San Francisco
next one up is Francis Scott Key Francis
Scott Key wrote the national anthem I
guess no surprise there because we know
leftists hate the national anthem
they've been protesting the national
anthem for a very long time now though
it is a little bit ironic that they took
down Francis Scott Key part of the
reason they did is there's a line in one
of the verses of the national anthem
that talks about slaves so the line is
no refuge could save the hireling and
slave from the terror of flight or the
gloom of the grave and there's there's
actually some debate over what this line
even means
but of course leftists are not looking
for context on that at all so the the
word slave there might actually refer to
the British policy of impressment of
enslaving people but again all nuance is
gone the other thing about Francis Scott
Key is though he owned slaves for a
period of his life he also publicly
criticized slavery he gave free legal
representation to slaves that were
seeking freedom but is that you had to
come down anyway and then I think that
the most ridiculous one this was the
third one over the weekend st. Junipero
Serra they are now pulling down actual
honest-to-goodness honest-to-god Saints
st. Mooney pero Sarah was a missionary
came to the new world in 1749 he was
canonized in 2015 by Pope Francis
there's a statue of him in the US
Capitol and believe it or not Nancy
Pelosi and Joe Biden actually paid their
respects to that statue not so long ago
that was then this
now they're gonna tear down every single
statue and then guess what once all the
statues are down they're coming for you
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the Michael Noel's show
president Trump talked about all this
statue toppling at his first speech
since the lockdown which we will get to
because this weekend more than any
should the real aim of these protests
and riots and it's a lot worse than
anybody thought and they're not just
gonna stop at statues first though I've
got to ask everybody in the comments
which major DC monument do you think
will be attacked first is it gonna be
the Lincoln is it gonna be the
Washington is it good I mean you've
already had I think was an academic came
out like an actual US professor at a big
University who described how best to
pull down the Washington Monument is
gonna be the Jefferson that one probably
could make sense it's gonna be something
else let me know what you think in the
comments section so President Trump
talked about all of this all of the
pulling down of statues a lot of normal
people most normal people opposed this
kind of stuff you'll notice when you
look at who was pulling down the statues
it's a lot of people clad in black they
look like they're part of far left
organizations either BLM which we'll get
to in one second or an Tifa or other
various anarchist and communist groups I
don't think they speak for most people
actually Muhammad Ali jr. son of the
famous boxer and the civil rights
advocate and social activist he came out
and strongly opposed all the statue
toppling in the riots and the looting in
the protests he said don't use colorful
language which I'll have to clean up a
little bit he goes don't bust up stuff
don't trash the place
you can peacefully protest my father
would have said they ain't nothing but
Devils my father said all lives matter I
don't think he'd agree with the BLM
movement actually Muhammad Ali jr. said
that he thought the BLM movement was
racist and then he went on to defend
cops he said police don't wake up and
think I'm going to kill an n-word today
or kill a white man they're just trying
to make it back home to their family in
one piece obviously correct
Muhammad Ali jr. I have been telling you
this for many weeks now that the black
lives matter organization is a very very
bad organism
it is not what it purports to be it is a
radical leftist anti-american no good
very bad organization and nobody should
have anything to do with it and as a
result of saying that I and others have
been called racist bigoted terrible
dishonest okay
well over the weekend the founders of
the black lives matter movement actually
admitted that my take on it is correct
okay there was I don't think they
admitted it over the weekend but the
video finally came out over the weekend
patrice color was caught on video
admitting that the BLM organization
isn't about black lives mattering that
she is a trained organizer and she is a
trained marxist i also think that it
might i think of a lot of things the
first thing I think is that we actually
do have an ideological frame myself
analicia in particular trained
organizers we are trained Marxists we
are super versed on sort of ideological
theories and I think that what we really
try to do is build a movement that could
be utilized by many many black folk when
someone tells you that he or she is a
Marxist believe them okay you hear a lot
of people ranting and raving about
conspiracy theories and tinfoil hats and
there are many people who rant and rave
about Marxism this woman is admitting it
you don't need to feel bad about
yourself if you posted the black square
you don't need to feel bad about
yourself if you posted the hashtag black
lives matter thinking the black lives
matter is about black lives mattering
but we now know it isn't we now have the
founders of BLM admitting on video in
their own words that this is a Marxist
front Marxists have duped plenty of nice
people in history Marxists have lied to
many of
nice people throughout history fool me
once shame on you fool me once shame on
you fool me twice shame on me I'm
remembering the George W Bush version of
this which is fool me twice the point is
you're not going to fool me again that
should be the point if they fool you the
first time and you post the black square
that's on them but if you continue to
give your support to the BLM
organization which is openly and a
validly Marxist radically ideological
radically anti-american that's on you
stop doing it stop posting the hashtag
stop posting the black square that's not
what this is about and this battle is
playing out not just in the United
States it's playing out all around the
world because over the weekend you had
the United Nations which we fund for
some reason openly embracing another
radical leftist organization another
communist / anarchist organization and
tithi we'll get to that in one second
first though I got to thank our friends
over at ancestry DNA ancestry DNA I've
been using ancestry since long before
the daily wire existed then ancestry
added the DNA component so you can go
even deeper in honor of the 75th
anniversary of the end of World War two
ancestry has just released a US draft
card collection from World War two with
over 36 million draft cards completed by
fighting aged men in the United States
across the country during that time
whether they ended up serving or not
super cool stuff I mean just for
instance my grandfather was a navigator
in a b24 during during World War two I
know a lot of us have grandparents who
fought you check out the draft cards
really cool a great way to find your
relatives in this collection help you
learn more about what their lives were
really like you know uncover your
ancestors personal details in that draft
card collection shows details like home
address physical description and more
get a new take on your ancestors World
War two experience and just broadly you
can build out your family tree I love it
I think it's such a great hobby
genealogy discover your untold stories
and more head to my URL at ancestry.com
/ Knowles Canada wles this
discovering your story today it's a
great hobby and it teaches you so much
not just about history generally but
about your history go to ancestry.com
slash Knowles caná-- wles the United
Nations is now pro in Tifa how much more
evidence do we need before we finally
defund the United Nations this should be
it
you've got BLM admitting that they're
marxist how much more evidence do you
need before you pull your support from
BLM same thing here with auntie fuh they
tweet quote UN hashtag Human Rights
experts express confound profound
concern over a recent statement by the
US Attorney General describing an Tifa
and other anti-fascist activities as
domestic terrorists saying it undermines
the rights to freedom of expression and
of peaceful assembly in the country see
how they're conflating an Tifa with
anti-fascists now auntie fuh is a
communist anarchist terror group
anti-fascist just means you oppose
fascism let's take that example all the
way back to when fascism had any sort of
meaning which is back in World War 2
with Mussolini
and sort of with Hitler though National
Socialism is sort of a different thing
but lumping both together fine that was
the last time the word fascism really
meant anything George Orwell wrote an
essay about this have after the Second
World War the word fascism lost all of
its meaning but in that war you see a
lot of leftists these days talking about
the Allied troops as the original
anti-fascists remember there were two
kinds of anti-fascists in world war two
there were the Americans and the British
our guys good guys and there were
Stalin's communists both anti-fascist
when you're just opposed to something
that leaves it wide open to
interpretation as to what side you are
actually on some anti fascists are good
right if you if you're an American
soldier in World War two that makes you
that's a good guy but if you're Stalin
just because you opposed Hitler at a
certain point doesn't make you a good
guy doesn't mean that I want to ally
with stop
okay and yet the United Nations
conflates the - we need to defund the
United Nations we pay 22% of the UN
budget to invite the worst people on
earth to sit on a Human Rights Council
some of the worst most despotic regimes
in history sit on a human's Rights
Council then they fly to New York to the
seat of the United Nations and criticize
the United States and we like masochists
pay the bill we say thank you Thank You
Venezuela may I have another thank you
North Korea North Korea Thank You Cuba
may I have another thank you Iran may I
have another why are we doing that the
UN is situated on beautiful waterfront
property we could knock down that
building we could bring in some nice
bulldozers we could create beautiful
Trump condominiums and we would save a
lot of money every single year now is
the time to do that we are in a battle
that has become ideological it's not
just in the u.s. its international but
it's the same issues what are we
fighting for why are we why are we
paying people and tolerating people
destroying our nation our history our
culture some conservatives some
conservatives go squishy on this they
say it's a good idea to take down the
statues take down the statues put them
in a museum I say we take down writers
and put them in prison but some
conservatives want to go along with the
leftist mob take down the statues and
put them in a museum very misguided
first of all they won't stay in museums
you think you're gonna take it down from
some public square and put it in a
museum and then go get to look at it no
they're coming down from museums to the
American Museum of Natural History in
New York just took down a muse of statue
of Teddy Roosevelt why what was so
terrible about Teddy Roosevelt nobody
can nobody can tell except that this
statue of Teddy Roosevelt had a black
man and an Indian in it and they didn't
like that for some reason too much
integration I guess so they're taking
down the statue
none of the statues that are going to
museums are going to remain there for
very long
there's no limiting principle to tearing
down the
choose to tearing down some statues but
not other statues of our history and
where the rubber meets the road I notice
for a lot of conservatives is robert e
lee many conservatives who want to prove
that they're not racist prove to leftist
mobs who don't care if you're not racist
and to whom we don't owe any sort of
explanation whatsoever
what those conservatives do is they say
ok we'll keep up Lincoln and Jefferson
they're really good guys in Washington
and even Christopher Columbus but will
tear down robert e lee cos robert e lee
as a traitor
this totally misunderstands the civil
war our nation broadly and how we look
at our history
if you want to tear down that robert e
lee's statue you find yourself exactly
at odds with Abraham Lincoln's vision
for what happens after the the Second
World War after the Second World War
after the Civil War we'll get to that in
one second first I got to thank our
friends over at first leaf I love
drinking high-quality wine you know that
and I love first leaf first leaf gave me
some freebies when they first came on
the show I drank all of those freebies
and now I continue to pay first leaf
because what a great wine club it is you
know what happens you're sitting at home
you've just finished a glass of wine
you're about to pour another one but
then the bottles empty you look around
there's no backup bottle this Spurs a
fear in you it's a fear that I call no
vino phobia novena phobia the fear of
running out of wine thanks to first leaf
you can get personalized boxes wine
shipped right to your door you get
incredible wine without leaving the
comfort of home first you take a quiz to
assess your wine drinking preferences
then first leaf sends you six expertly
picked bottles of wine based on your
answers they have a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee
you go and you rate the bottles and then
over time the more you use it the better
first leaf gets accustomed to fitting
your flavor profiles one hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee sign up today get
six bottles of wine for only twenty nine
ninety five plus free shipping go to try
first leaf comm slash Noel's canna wles
that is six bottles of wine for only
29.95 at try first leaf dot-com slash
Knowles
here's the issue with tearing down the
robert e lee's statue you say
conservatives are traitors robert e lee
was a traitor
first of all robert e lee was a great
American general who only returned to
Virginia when war broke out because he
was loyal to the Commonwealth of
Virginia as a federalist right you have
more local loyalties before the National
loyalty in an issue like that but then
he was instrumental in bringing about an
end of the war and Abraham Lincoln made
an excellent point on how the war should
end he said with malice toward none with
charity for all we will finish up this
conflict that was good enough for the
men who fought and won the Civil War
that was good enough for the men who
lost their brothers and arms in the
Civil War that was good enough for the
families who lost loved ones in the
Civil War but it's not good enough for
modern leftists robert e lee had his
citizenship reinstated it's good enough
for people who came before us not good
enough for modern leftists when there is
a civil war often that's that spells the
end of a nation but the nation did come
back together that was not easy it took
a lot of healing it took a lot of
compassion for our fellow citizens
rebuilding love of our fellow citizens
we succeeded at that and now 150 years
later more than 150 years later people
are trying to tear that apart again
totally undoing all the good that
Lincoln and those who came after him did
the other reason why we can't tear down
Robert II layer why we shouldn't tear
down Robert Ely is that the argument for
tearing down Lee is an argument for
tearing down everybody
Rob robert e lee's an American citizen
so I don't think the traitor line works
really what you're saying he's a traitor
he's a racist he's a bigot you apply it
to Jefferson in Washington really what
people are saying is this man
had flaws this man committed sins this
man was not perfect this the statue of
the perfect man who has lived any time
in the last 2,000 years or so would be
an empty statue would just be a platform
if that's your argument for tearing down
Lee then you have to tear down all of
the statues - and not just tear down the
statues you have to rename the
institutions over the weekend hashtag
cancel Yale was trending nationwide what
did yell do Yale has done many things in
history but one thing it did was push
forward this progressive idea that we've
got to rename things tear down statues
Yale renamed Calhoun College just a few
years ago because it was named after a
guy who defended slavery and you can't
have that so all these years later we
have to rename Calhoun College at the
time
Roger Kimball wrote an essay where he
pointed out that if you rename Calvin
College you got it renamed Yale because
Calhoun might have defended slavery but
Eli Yale was a slave trader
the man who Yale is named after so you
got to rename Yale Jesse Kelly the
conservative commentator talked about
this over the weekend and Coulter has
been talking about this for a while and
it's very ironic it's a little bit
chickens coming home to roost because
Yale in recent years more or less kicked
off the canceled culture perhaps you
remember shrieking girl that Yale
undergraduate who met her professor who
was the head of the college that she was
in and started shrieking at him because
his wife had the audacity to suggest
that Yale students were able to choose
their own Halloween costumes he was
defending a principle of free speech and
maturity and adulthood she didn't like
that so she went on a vulgar rant
shrieking about how he should lose his
job
your jobs to create a place of comfort
and film for the students that prison
syllabus but send me an email your
position that's the future that's the
future president shrieking girl whew
future senator shrieking undergraduate
guess what Yale did they didn't support
the professors professors ended up
leaving Yale I think now they've come
back but they ended up leaving they did
step down the students won many of the
students involved in that altercation
won awards for social justice at
graduation what happened to Yale that's
what many of us were asking ourselves
what happened to this place that they
allowed this to happen then it occurred
to me
Yale was founded as a seminary and it
still is one Yale was founded as a place
to Train priests and preachers and it
still does that all of the elite
universities were founded as seminaries
and they are seminaries to this day the
difference is that initially they were
seminaries of Christianity today they
are seminaries of liberalism of woek ism
of leftism call it what you want
they still train their students
indoctrinate their students with the
same exact religious zeal that they had
when they were founded but the religion
has changed a little bit whereas we
began with Christianity now we are at
liberalism and of course if you're going
to train students in that new woke
religion then you're gonna get zealots
like that girl shrieking at her
professor and you are gonna get zealots
renaming everything a other revolution
the sad thing about all these elite
institutions don't forget university is
going back to the Middle Ages the
earliest university
were outgrowths of the Catholic Church
they were places to Train monks and
priests people in the faith and now
there's a new faith in Christianity
though you have Redemption because you
recognize man's fallen nature and then
you recognize your need of a redeemer
and then you recognize that a redeemer
actually came and redeemed mankind on
the cross and rose from the dead in
leftism there's no redemption in the
religion of liberalism there is an
inversion of Christianity you are told
that you're you're perfect just the way
you are and if you're not perfect you
can become perfect through your own
actions through your own self liberation
from bondage from the oppressive past
into the new future you can perfect your
own human nature if there is some
imperfection it's society's fault it's
not your fault and if there is some
imperfection there's no redemption for
it because there's no Redeemer that's
the sort of religion the topple statues
the original religion of our seminaries
built up all of the statues built up
this great country and the new one is
tearing them down there is no middle
ground in this political battle there is
no compromise there's no reconciliation
there's no meet in the middle there's no
meet in the middle between build a
statue and tear a statue down you can't
you can leave a statue up I guess but
that's not really in the middle that's
the former category that's building up a
nation there's not going to be any
middle ground here we are playing for
keeps it is a battle over keeping our
country which means to continue to build
our country or tearing our country down
completely and once they get past the
statues they're not going to be happy
they're gonna go for the more
institutions they're gonna go for you
President Trump talked about this in his
first rally since the coronavirus
lockdown and he talked about his
strategy a lot of us including on this
show we've talked about why is President
Trump allowing this to happen why won't
he roll the tanks into chas chop Somalia
soybean
whatever you want to call it why won't
he do it one thought has been that
perhaps he wants people to see how bad
things get Trump knows a lot about
stagecraft and about the media maybe he
wants people to see the city's burning
and then realized that we need law and
order we have to vote for him I think
that's a tough strategy but actually at
his rally over the weekend Trump
admitted that this is exactly what he's
doing
all of these places I talked about are
Democrat you know that every one of them
and I have an offer out I said any time
you want we'll come in we'll straighten
it out in one hour or less now I may be
wrong but it's probably better for us to
just watch that disaster
I flew in with some of our great
congressmen who were going to introduce
in a second and I said to congressman
what do you think I can straighten it
out fast should we just go in no sir let
it simmer for a little while let people
see what radical left Democrats will do
to our country he makes a great point
here and confirms what a lot of us
thought was happening and even more than
that he gives you a peek into his
thinking if President Trump were
secretly letting the cities burn just so
that we could see how bad it was gonna
get I think a lot of people would accuse
him of cynicism saying ah you're willing
to let cities go up in flames just to
make a political point but the very fact
that Trump is telling you what he's
doing takes away that cynicism right
he's he's admitting it to you there's no
guile here and I that's the point of
these rallies is to take you behind the
scenes create this personal connection
and I think he does that pretty
successfully the one trouble with the
strategy though is that we no longer
live in a country that recognizes
federalism very clearly we don't really
understand if you asked 100 people on
the street probably very few of them
would recognize that we have local
government state government federal
government and actually the local
government makes most of the decisions
that administers most of the laws and
regulations and the state government a
little bit more - and the federal
government has relatively few powers
narrowly defined powers most people
wouldn't recognize that because it's
become less and less true over time so
you look around at the burning cities I
think a lot of people look at Trump and
say well you're the president do
something about it action is a good spur
to enthusiasm action is very inspiring
and so Trump is playing a game here
that's why he had said I I admit I could
be wrong about this but I think it's
better to let people see what happens I
think what needs to happen is a little
bit of a combination of the two I think
it's good to watch as and chop it's
hilarious it's it's sort of like when
proposed the green new deal which was so
absurd and Mitch McConnell immediately
said well we got a vote on this ASAP we
got to get the green new deal on the
docket we got to get everybody on the
record
do you support destroying ninety percent
of American energy do you support
spending ninety-three trillion dollars
get on the record senator there is a
little bit of that that performance of
seeing how bad it is but we also need to
see action we have elected Trump in part
for his energy
we had other candidates who Trump
perhaps aptly described as low-energy
Trump is high energy so we want to see
that energy in action Alexander Hamilton
running in the Federalists said that we
want an energetic executive and
energetic government so we do have to
see that eventually when is that going
to be perhaps we'll have to wait and see
Trump took us a little more behind the
scenes throughout the rest of this rally
I thought it was overall an OK rally but
the mainstream media are knocking him
for one thing and one thing in
particular the crowd sizes were
underwhelming why was that we will get
to it there is a conspiracy afoot which
the left is admitting just like black
lives matter admits that it's Marxist
just like the UN admits that it supports
an Tifa but there is a campaign problem
to get to both first I want to thank you
for helping us make it to 75,000
subscribers on YouTube if you wouldn't
mind if you wouldn't mind helping me out
let's try to get it to 100,000 you're
probably watching this if you're
watching it on The Daily wire YouTube
page head on over to the Michael Noel's
Show YouTube channel we have some great
interviews coming up very soon we've got
some bonus segments and breakouts up to
we have a new special on red pilled
Chris Rock and we have my reaction to
some of president Trump's most hilarious
moments so far also if you are not
already a daily wire member you should
consider getting a reader's pass to
daily wire calm the readers pass is just
three bucks a month you're never going
to remember three bucks a month right
now we'll take two-thirds off that you
get the first month for just 99 cents
and you get members only content so
here's one from Shapiro this is eight
leftist lies that are destroying
American you can see is pretty long
content much more in-depth probably then
you would be used to just from the main
public website so go check it out I
think it's really important these days
especially as the media are lying
about everything head on over daily
wired I come / subscribe we'll be right
back with a whole lot more
so Trump talks about his strategy on the
riots then he gets even more personal
than that he goes on this digression
about how he was giving a speech at West
Point and he tried walking down the ramp
at the ramp was slippery so he had to
walk slowly
most people are criticizing Trump for
this they think this was a waste of time
at his rally I think it's the key
feature to his rally here is Trump
talking about that all-important shuffle
down the ramp and this was a steel ramp
you all saw it cuz everybody saw this
was a steel ramp it had no handrail it
was like an ice skating rink and I said
general I have a problem that he didn't
understand that at first I said there's
no way he understood I just saluted
almost 600 times I just made a big
speech I set for other speeches I'm
being baked I'm being baked like a cake
I said general there's no way I can make
it down that ramp without falling on my
ass general I have no really
it's true so I said is there like
something else around sir the ramp is
ready to go grab me sir grab me I didn't
really want to grab him you know why cuz
I said that'll be a story - he takes you
through you know I don't like it when
the president uses vulgar language in
public but the story does seem to call
for it and I see what he's doing here
the media for how long for a week
basically talked about at Trump was old
and doddering by walking down this ramp
meanwhile their candidate is Joe Biden
enough said but he the II talk they talk
about the ramp for a week so he wants to
take you behind the scenes on all these
little moments at one point the media
accused him of maybe having Parkinson's
disease Trump jokes about this goes on a
several minute long rant basically a
stand-up comedy bit about how when
you're drinking water it's a good idea
not to spill it on your silk necktie you
had on a very good red tie that's just
sort of expensive its silk because they
should they look better they have a
better Sheen to them and I don't want to
get water on the time and I don't want
to drink much so lift it up the water I
see we have a little glass of water
where the hell did this water come from
where did it come from and I look down
on my tie because I've done it I've
taken water and it spills down in geotag
does it look good for a long time and
frankly the tie is never the same so I
put it up to my lip and then I say
because they know what a sophisticated
and they gave me though the disease
they gave me another disease so he takes
a sip of the water
anything else a water to decide
president Trump
sips the water and then he throws it off
the stage the guy gets stagecraft so
well and you were watching you say why
am i watching the president United
States talking about how silk neckties
have a better Sheen and now you don't
want to dribble water on it because
they're kind of expensive meanwhile this
guy's a billionaire it's very very funny
it's very very personal and it makes you
have a much tighter connection to the
man speaking then you have to the
mainstream media that are lying about
him and it makes you trust him more than
you trust them I actually think this
kind of stuff
the tie bit all of that is some of the
most important stuff in the speech he
probably could have cut it down a little
bit in terms of the length of time but
it was really good stuff then he shows
you why this personal stuff matters
because he pivots from a story that
isn't completely trivial like the ramp
or the necktie he pivots into a personal
story about negotiating over the price
of an aircraft and now all of a sudden
very subtly before anybody know what
happened
Trump blends the personal element and
the political element and he shows you
his political philosophy which more or
less boils down to make good deals I
said cancel the contract I want to
cancel I said general can you cancel the
contract he said yes sir I'm very proud
of it
oh good cancel it okay sir by the way to
cancel it you have to pay anything yes
sir
we have a cancellation fee sir how much
is it general two hundred and fifty
million dollars sir I said what
sir we made a good deal 250 millions of
kid you mean if we don't buy the played
we have to hand them 250 million that's
not good right take a look at these two
guys they're looking by the way that's
like a good story compared to some I
could tell you like with aircraft
carriers so I say general don't cancel
don't cancel just tell them I don't want
the planes don't put anything in writing
don't put it in writing general why sir
because I don't want to pay 250 you
don't want to pay 250 the speech was
largely like this it was much funnier
than Dave Chappelle's recent stand-up
special on Netflix right that this is
Trump's superpower and he does it very
well why does this matter well because
most politicians they don't care about
250 million 250 million is a drop in the
bucket of our federal budget it's a
rounding error so nobody worries about
that Trump is showing you he does worry
about that that the president United
States a leader of the free world is
personally negotiating over the cost of
airplanes because most politicians don't
care about the stuff but most Americans
do budget they think about things even
if you go buy a t-shirt or you go buy a
box of cereal or something you or you're
looking at the numbers you say ok well I
don't want to spend $5.00 I'd rather
spend $4 I don't wanna spend $15 Reza
spent $14 and you're thinking about
these things
it's very relatable it shows you that
this guy is different from everyone in
Washington and he's much more like you
he then moves on to more ideological
questions and in this question I think
shows a major debate that's going on on
the right right now between the old kind
of more libertarian consensus and the
new more conservative traditional idea
that's emerging and this is on the
question of flag-burning as president
Trump echoed a sentiment he's mentioned
before sentiment that I have supported
on this show which is we ought to have
laws or a constitutional amendment I
suppose in this country against burning
the American flag and you know we ought
to do something mister senators we have
two great senators we ought to come up
with legislation that if
burn the American flag you go to jail
for one year one year
this is a great idea I know that some
conservatives are going to shrink back
instinctively like if you're in a
doctor's office and he hits the hammer
on your knee and the knee goes up you're
going to shrink back at that because we
support free speech so you can't be for
a flag burning anti flag burning
amendment right wrong not quite what's
the issue here the issue is the debate
are conservatives going to get serious
or we going to let the left run
roughshod over the country for a long
time in this country for most of our
nation's history we've had laws against
burning the flag for a lot longer than
we haven't had laws against burning the
flag this was just part of our
ordination than this this was challenged
in recent decades and it was found to be
unconstitutional to have a law against
burning the American flag and actually
Antonin Scalia the great originalist
justice was one of the people who
opposed who found that it was
unconstitutional to have an amendment or
a law against burning the American flag
the Conservatives tended to support the
flag burning laws liberals opposed the
flag burning laws Scalia sided with the
Liberals on constitutional grounds
because he said that burning the
American flag is clearly an expressive
action it clearly is about political
speech and so those laws are
unconstitutional now one solution to
this would be pass a constitutional
amendment saying you can't desecrate the
American flag because in some cases when
you want to dispose of an old American
flag a tattered America like you do burn
it we're not worried about the burning
it's the desecration that we don't like
I think this is a very good idea there's
a reason why we for most of our
country's history had laws against
burning the American flag and we all
thought that they were perfectly
constitutional it's because it's
incoherent to burn the American flag and
to do so in the name of the First
Amendment because the American flag is
the symbol of the whole country the
country which includes in it the First
Amendment if you burn the American flag
you are burning symbolically the First
Amendment and so it's an act that
doesn't make any sense
moreover I mean I think of it in the way
that G K Chesterton talked about how
there is a thought that stops thought
and that is the only thought
to be stopped there is free expression
that stops free expression and that is
the only free expression that ought to
be stopped by the lights of the First
Amendment that would be something like
burning a flag another reason is that
nations need to have things that hold
them together and when a mayor in the
early days of America we all shared
we shared largely a common actual
ancestry in the anglo-american tradition
we shared a language we shared political
institutions we shared a religion we
shared all of these things and
increasingly over time we don't share
those things anymore we don't share any
of those things really you need to have
something that holds you together and if
you can't even agree on the symbol of
the whole country then there's nothing
left another reason this is a great idea
and why it's it's actually conservative
to have an amendment a constitutional
amendment against burning the American
flag is that the conservative worldview
needs to have not just form but
substance it needs to have not just
procedure
but actual stuff so for instance we
support free expression we support the
First Amendment but we also need to
support specific things to express I
can't just be you're free to make any
decision you want
well what decision are you gonna make
it's like the pro-choice people they say
we're pro-choice okay you're choosing to
do what really what they mean is they're
pro-abortion we need to have stuff to
our conservatism for the last 50 60
years conservatism has more or less just
boiled down to procedure we're okay
we're going to oppose the the certain
procedures that are destroying America
but if you use the right procedure to
tear down statues that's a good thing or
even on the question of immigration as
we let him more and more and more
immigrants in the country and lose less
and less and less assimilation we say
okay well we can of course we would
never oppose that left-wing policy but
you've got to do it legally you got to
follow the right procedure but we're not
going to pose you on the substance we
need to have some substance to it we've
seen the effects look at originalism
we've said we need to have these
originalist judges they don't need to
have any conservative content but they
need to file this proceed
of interpretive principle well guess
what we've lost virtually every
important case over the last twenty
thirty years forty years more than that
the procedure is not enough we need to
have substance we need to stand for
something I think that would be a good
future for the conservative movement
frankly I think it's the only future if
we want to stop before all the statues
and all all of our country is tumbled
down and of course no one is talking
about the substantive points of that
rally everyone is just talking about the
crowd sizes so the left is now attacking
Trump for not having a big enough crowd
we were promised a zillion people were
going to show up and then there weren't
as many ironically before the rally the
left was preemptively attacking Trump
for having too many people at the rally
he was gonna have too many people who's
gonna spread coronavirus then there they
were were spaced out there were some
empty seats there making fun of Trump
for having not enough people three
theories of this was their intimidation
outside the rally was it left to
sabotage or was it lack of enthusiasm
for Trump we know that there was left to
sabotage aoc admitted it she said
actually you got rocked by teens on
tick-tock who flooded the Trump campaign
with fake ticket reservations and
tricked you into believing a million
people wanted your white supremacist
open-mike to pack an arena during Kovich
a doubt to Zoomers you all make me so
Pratt's she was saying was teenagers who
did all this turns out it wasn't really
teenagers it was older leftist activists
here's one woman admitting as aoc did
that she she was pushing for all of this
a woman named Mary Jo lap who does not
exactly look like a teen or resume her
but here's the tick-tock she made if
you've been paying attention to the news
you know the Donald Trump is planning on
holding his first political rally post
quarantine on June 19th in Tulsa
Oklahoma now if you tell that's a big
deal I want you to Google two phrases
Juneteenth
and black Wall Street you'll find out
why people are really upset about this
so why it's a slap in the face to the
black community somebody on another
tick-tock Post commented that he was
offering two free tickets on his
campaign website to go to this rally so
I wouldn't investigated it it's two free
tickets per cell phone number because
when you register you have to give them
your cell phone number they send you a
code you put the code in and your
tickets are reserved for you
so this probably means having worked on
a political campaign this past fall it
probably means that
getting text messages from his campaign
all I have to do to get rid of those is
tech stop that's all you have to do once
you tap stop they have to stop texting
you that's the lot they have to leave
you alone so I recommend that all of
those of us that want to see this 19
thousand seat auditorium barely filled
or completely empty go reserve tickets
now and leave him standing there alone
on the stage what do you say okay so she
admits it
AOC admits that there was some sabotage
going on there were some protesters out
there or intimidate protesters
intimidating Trump supporters who wanted
to come in I think there's also a
campaign issue the campaign could have
handled this better we know that the
left pulls these sort of tactics they do
this to every speech that I give on
campus they always reserve a lot more
seats and then they either don't show up
or they show up and they leave early
that's why we have an and a wait list
line outside to immediately fill in the
seats I was actually giving a speech
about six or eight months ago defending
George Washington at George Washington
University in Washington DC you might
say that I saw this coming
this toppling of the Washington statues
so I was giving a defense of Washington
and at a certain point about five ten
minutes in whole group of leftists left
and we immediately filled the seats back
in campaigns you seen that coming and
the campaign should not have caved to
the mob on moving the date you remember
the initially the Trump rally were
supposed to be on June 19th
Juneteenth now the most important
holiday in all of America Juneteenth is
the day that Republicans told the slaves
in Texas that they were free and this is
somehow become a political issue for
Democrats I don't know how that how they
managed to do that so they said the
Trump campaign has to move the rally
can't be on June 19th June 10th and the
Trump campaign acquiesced to this this
shouldn't have done that first of all it
created some confusion over when the
rally was and it dispirited people
because they caved to the leftist mob
needlessly
and counterproductive ly so I think the
campaign should learn some lessons from
this be better prepared next time look
this was the first rally set in three
months right since the lock downs that's
fine the important thing is we need to
get back out there and see some more
rallies the canceled culture the statue
toppling the anti-american
activities are going to continue all
right they're already trying you know
they can
Christopher Columbus a long time ago
they're now trying to rename Columbus
Ohio as I said would certainly happen
they if you take down a statue of
Columbus at Columbus High School in
Columbus Ohio the next question is why
the high school named after or though
cut the community college named after
Columbus why is the town named after
Columbus so they want to change the name
and I think this encapsulates the whole
of liberal modernity they want to change
the name of Columbus Ohio to flavor town
flavor town Ohio this is what they say
about they say Columbus is an amazing
city but one whose name is tarnished by
the very name itself its namesake
Christopher Columbus is in the bad place
by which they mean hell but they can't
use the word hell because they have a
very religious worldview but they don't
have our religious worldview they've
replaced it with leftism he's in the bad
place because of all his raping slave
trading in genocide that's not exactly a
proud legacy so again they get Columbus
completely wrong they accuse him of
crimes he did not commit but you don't
expect historical literacy from people
who would name a town flavortown
why not rename the city flavortown
the name is twofold one it honors
central Ohio's proud heritage as a
culinary crossroads in one of the
nation's largest test markets for the
food industry second chef Liberty Guy
Fieri was born in Columbus so we can
honor him this is what happens in
liberalism liberalism and this happens
as liberalism spreads out not just over
time but geographically it replaces real
culture profound culture real history
real literature real art real tradition
with nothing but consumption nothing but
the idea that we should feed our
appetites in this case literally feed
our appetites with debased pop-culture
and cheap food cheap salty fatty food
feed me feed me feed me we have
squandered our culture on our own
ravenous appetites that's what happens
the old idea of Liberty the old idea of
freedom is that we have to tame our
appetites so that we can conquer our
passions and actually be free in the
world and the modern liberal idea of
Liberty is you
give in to your passions you've given to
your appetites and only when you do
exactly what you want to do whenever you
want to do it then only are you free
what culture do you want to live in
we're we're all headed toward flavortown
folks when the last statue finally Falls
then we will be living in flavortown USA
is that is that the culture you want you
want to live in the world of George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson and
Abraham Lincoln and our beautiful
monuments and our religion and our
traditions and our institutions or do
you want to live in flavortown
unfortunately these days probably most
people want to live in flavortown not a
good sign for our country though that's
our show we got more to get to we'll do
it tomorrow I'm Michael gnosis the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies executive producer Jeremy
borin supervising producers Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling technical
producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup nikka Geneva
production assistant Ryan love the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
clay bird show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me Andrew
Clayton
[Music]